when you create a new category it takes
time
it takes more more of the analytical
uh
thought process it takes more
experimenting you just speak with more
and more people
end users partners uh people in in the
industry
um and yes it it wasn't easy uh it isn't
trivial but i think the moment you kind
of find
find that and you know find the product
market fit really and then also to go to
market
that is uh
that's you know is that's the point
where everything kind of changes
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet roy
degan the ceo of secure
a leading security and iot expert with
over 15 years of experience in product
management and business development from
various high-tech companies
prior to co-founding security things roy
led product groups and successfully
launched multiple product lines in the
cyber security risk management and
intelligence domains at companies
including rsa the security division of
emc
nice systems and payoneer
roy served in various positions in the
idf elite technological unit and holds
the bachelors of science in computer
science and management from tel aviv
university
roy degen welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here i'm so
excited for these next 20 minutes how
are you
good good michael how's it going
i'm i'm doing well thank you very very
much it's a stormy evening here in tel
aviv for the both of us but we're we're
warm and cozy and i'm excited to have
this you know authentic and fun
conversation with you both about you
know internet of things and what's been
happening to our world and how in how
the hell can we you know maintain them
uh both infrastructure wise and secure
wise at scale but also a little bit
about yourself and you know who you are
as a ceo and as a leader and and tying
it a little bit to some of the other
things that you do in life so we're
gonna have a great conversation rory
tell me a little bit about secure things
and and how that whole thing started
sure happy to do that so uh secure
things uh we started a few years ago
initially kind of focused on iot cyber
security uh that was kind of the main
topic that we wanted a challenge we
wanted to tackle and then what we saw is
that um you know if initially we tried
to target
more address manufacturers uh we
actually decided to focus on enterprises
because we see the the challenges that
enterprises have are huge
um and again with that cyber security
offering the second thing once we
started speaking with more and more
enterprises and more partners in this
ecosystem of iot
we actually discovered that cyber
security is part just part of the pain
right so the pain is definitely cyber
security and especially when it comes to
these devices but it also includes
aspects of compliance
which is kind of in between and also the
operational management of these devices
so you have a lot of devices you don't
even know if they're working properly or
not um and that's kind of where we
decided okay this is this is the thing
this is what the market needs yeah and
we decided to
embark on that journey and also create a
new category uh which we coined the term
uh earlier last year which is iot ops uh
so what we do today is really iot ops uh
and we're really helping enterprises
manage these devices in an efficient and
secure
manner and that's all we are about and
you know if you think about it we're
kind of creating an equivalent it system
for these iot spaces for these teams
which are responsible for those devices
what's happening in the world you know
pay me you know take me 30 000 feet in
the air
you know what what is happening today
with iot devices why is this the right
timing for secure things
interesting question and i think a lot
of things are happening so first you
know uh digitization so more and more uh
ip based devices uh meeting you know for
years uh have been meeting networks and
have been meeting enterprises and then
just proliferation of devices
and what you're seeing is from an
enterprise perspective they're not just
working with a single vendor single
thermal version single model of a device
they just it's all over the place so
they have many types of devices many
versions uh many models um and
different capabilities with these
devices uh so that's one thing so it's
kind of the proliferation uh then it's
the lack of consolidation okay so they
have different systems that they need to
work with in in the best case they have
a system in other cases they they don't
really have that system uh and it's
really then challenging to know from a
single kind of pane of glass what's
going on
then the next thing which was seeing it
happening is there was also
uh the people which are responsible for
these devices now are pretty much you
know they have i.t capabilities nowadays
so they kind of know okay there is a
better way to do these things that were
doing you know they were doing either
manual or very reactive after the fact
and they're seeing kind of their the iit
counterparts and the id counterparts
have so many systems right you know how
many categories there are in you know
the id space how many systems and tools
and they're like okay we're missing
something there's definitely a better
way to do this
um and you know we actually saw that
over the last course of the last few
years and that's why i said okay we need
to create that equivalent of the ic
system for these guys and you know it's
pretty exciting because it's a new
category uh and once you know they see
the the presentation they see the demo
like wow when can we have it deployed
and then you know we also talk speak
with them about how simple is deployed
exactly and we speak with them about
simple it is to deploy which is also
surprising for them because there is a
really long project of deployment of the
devices themselves and we're like no we
can deploy in less than a day
um and then you just see once we deploy
they're like oh this is nice this is
neat so yeah it's it's it's pretty
exciting and i think you know generally
working on a new category is is hard but
it's it's the reward is amazing
i love it and so you created this
company and today you're you're sort of
leading this ship and you know just like
any leader you're faced with tremendous
challenges and you know i truly believe
that every person you know in the world
is a leader in their own domain a role
model for somebody
somebody that's always looking up to uh
but
you know you have a more difficult task
because you literally chose a leadership
position and facing the trenches of a
startup life
first of all why
why do you need to be the leader of the
startup
oh it's easy no startups are easy
um
that's what i've heard
yeah no why i don't know it's a it's
kind of uh like somehow someone said a
few years ago to me he said it's kind of
a bug you need to get it out of the
system
uh right uh if you have that bug you you
just you know you need to and i've kind
of known it for years so i worked for
various corporates right i worked for
rsa worked for nia systems i worked
smaller companies pioneer and other
companies uh but it was always
there you know also if we go back you
know intelligence
uh units um and it was always there so
it's just a matter of when is the right
time uh to start and you know work on
the startup and i think it's um
it's you know thinking about okay this
is how how we're gonna grow and create
something big and you know add more
people and it's every kind of milestone
that you reach is so rewarding it's so
fun you know and you see more people
join a team and you know everyone you
know it's it's great relationships and
you become friends and i think it's
really about that kind of journey and
it's uh
it's pretty unique in my opinion you
know that startup journey obviously yes
it is it's not easy it's definitely not
easy but uh it's it's rewarding
is it all
based on intuition you know reaching all
these new experiences all these new
struggles and trying to sort of climb
out of climb out of them and using your
intuition is that is that how it works
for you or how do you go through about
this you know leadership thinking
process
um so i think it's a combination of
being uh analytical uh intuition and
experimenting
right you you like you look at a problem
like you want to solve okay what is the
um and you know in my career my entire
career has been around product
management and leading product
management teams uh so i kind of think
as that kind of product manager
um and you kind of see this challenge
and you're like okay i have a guess
this is what i'm gonna i'm gonna do so
it's kind of being analytical about the
data you have uh putting your own uh
intuition into that but then
experimenting you know um you know and
start quick and fail fast right uh but
then experiment and do it again uh so
that's kind of the way the way i see it
and the way we you know it's also the
rest of the company that's the the way
we work obviously being careful like if
the the product the solution is in the
hands of the huge customers uh but still
we're kind of in that kind of uh you
know agile very agile mode
so you're talking about this thin
balance between
uh the being analytical being
experimental having the intuition and
now i i saw that you were
competing for rock climbing for many
years and you know i can reflect back to
maybe one or two experiences that i've
only had you know rock climbing but but
i reflecting you know looking at this
whether it's you know bouldering or
whether it's climbing high
there's something that's very analytical
experimental and intuitive about the
process of defeating this rock right
yeah it's actually true and i think
so i used to compete back when i went
more when i was younger when i was a kid
for years
but i've been climbing pretty much since
i was uh 13
uh i guess wow um and i think it kind of
puts you in this uh certain state of
mind
right uh because it kind of makes you
what you are as a client but at least
after so many years of climbing and
especially when you're kind of growing
up as a kid and you know spending most
of your time in the in the climbing gym
or outdoors um and yeah it becomes you
kind of you look at this you know you
come to the gym and you look and you're
with friends you look at this route and
you say okay this i can do this this is
easy right you start the first move oh
no this is harder than i thought
and then you get to the kind of mindset
that you need to have that level of
tenacity and endurance
and you need to kind of get to that
state of mind and you kind of become
fixated with this uh you know with this
route that you want to send that you
want to finish and it's similar to kind
of the startup you know experience
uh where you really want to
focus on startup grow it but also again
have the tenacity and endurance
and believe in the mission and the team
and what you're doing but always kind of
fix it so also in climbing you know
in between sessions you're thinking
about the rally you become fixated about
it you think okay how am i gonna come
next time to the next session i'm gonna
do some moves differently i'm gonna work
in between sessions and you know
improving some core strength or
something and then i'm gonna get it and
the same kind of you know the iterations
that you have uh within the startup so i
think it's a lot of it uh which kind of
um uh it's part of the
what got me to kind of where where i am
today
is it also similar on a mental level and
on an emotional level you know when
you're sitting there and you're alone in
front of the rock and it's basically
you're trying not to figure out what you
need to do better obviously here at a
startup you have a team behind you but
but still with the team
you oftentimes have to make a decision
and that decision is not trivial and
then you have to sort of guide this
whole process the whole ship towards the
decision that you do believe is right
but the way to get there is not
traveling you might have to do many
iterations to get there
yeah so i think there's multiple things
here which you just mentioned then they
kind of i can relate from the world of
climbing so one
um it's kind of being the zone
right uh and yeah you have a team around
you but and you have you know friends
where you're climbing uh but i remember
especially when competing as a kid um
there's audience and there's it's
there's a lot of noise and the crowd is
cheering but the moment you start your
attempt
that's it
it's kind of you know it's noise
cancellation you can't hear anything
you're just focused on what you need to
get done and you just again you're in
that moment and in that zone and also in
startup sometimes you need to change
kind of the you know state of mind
sometimes yeah you're listening to
everyone and you're kind of getting
advice from from the team and for other
people and at certain times you need to
kind of be in the zone and say okay guys
this is what we're doing we're in the
zone yes let's uh focus on this there'll
be a lot of noise a lot of competition
all of this a lot of that but we need to
be focused on on what we're doing and
what we want to want to achieve uh
there's definitely also the aspects of
teamwork and how you know we're we're
improving
um you know together as a team and also
the kind of the advice you get from you
know other people whether it's you know
advisors or experts or the the team
itself and it's the same kind of in
climbing and having that kind of uh
counterparts which are working with you
on that attempt or throughout you know
just friends which you climb with
together um so that there's definitely
some resemblance there
so going back to the the day-to-day of
of secure things you know where's the
exhilaration for you right i mean it
sounds like you you opt in for a lot of
adventures and you've had quite a lot of
experiences in your life from relocating
to competing to working at some some
companies that i love and and that
they're helping power the show as well
but
you know where where is the acceleration
for you
both in the day-to-day of the company
but also on the macro level of where
you're trying to build here
so so many areas uh you know and there's
uh so many milestones that you get to
you know it can be funding
milestones which are important and you
know you then also tell the rest of the
team and everybody is excited so for me
seeing also the team excited about each
of these milestones so funding you know
seeing how they uh think about it is
great
um it's also you know i remember like
putting the the product in the hands of
the first few customers and seeing how
they react but again it's also for me
it's always looking okay how is the team
how do they feel about it and you know
getting the feedback
from end customers and how hand
customers also talk about the team and
the service we provide that for me is is
is is amazing that's a a great um
achievement kind of i feel personally
and then you know it's also the bigger
bigger mission that we're
creating a new category we're trying to
kind of uh you know change the space uh
we're kind of digitizing the space which
has kind of been
left behind i'd say and putting a
solution which is really kind of
changing
the lives of our you know the customers
the end users uh and seeing their
appreciation of it and you know how it
helps them on the day-to-day
that for me is you know it's it's pretty
again pretty unique
where you know if you're looking back at
the beginning of of secure things how
trivial was this for you that this is a
problem that needs to be solved because
you're talking about the new market
you're talking about a new category
you're talking about iot ops this is the
first time i'm hearing of the term iot
ops
how how obvious and how intuitive was
this for you versus how much research
you have to do to to sort of you know
find your way to this problem
um it took us time so it's definitely
when you create a new category it takes
time
it takes more more the analytical
thought process it takes more
experimenting you just speak with more
and more people uh
end users
partners uh people that are in in the
industry
and yes it it wasn't easy
it isn't trivial but i think the moment
you kind of find
find that and you know find the product
market fit really and then also to go to
market fit
that is uh
[Music]
that's you know it is that's the point
where everything kind of uh changes
right that's the point where everything
kind of starts accelerating um and you
just need to kind of
i'm always that
i'm always fascinated sorry to introduce
because i'm always so fascinated
that you just said that this moment that
you were understanding that okay we have
this product market fit and we're we're
ready to go like we have this conviction
we have our team behind me and you know
i can just imagine you know you're in
the position of the ceo saying like
having that feeling like wow
i know we were reaching product market
fair and i can't wait to share this
feeling with my whole team
was there a specific moment that this
happened or did this happen gradually as
you were building out secure things
so
i think
it happened over time because
for me i believe like you know as a kind
of product manager uh there's different
level of product market fit
right and product market fair also
includes marketing and messaging and a
lot of things and it takes constant
iterations and constant improvements and
also that at the same time the market is
also changing right and you always need
to continue so improving and
accelerating so
there is a single point where you
probably you know the first few
customers that start working with this
and say okay yes this is amazing but
then it's it's it's a kind of it's it's
continuing and it's always happening and
you can always improve that product
market fit so it's not that point of
time which boom that's it we're done
it's okay now it's more marketing now
it's the sales machine and how we build
that and how we do we um uh really um
but it's the feeling that's in the way
is the vibe different at that point is
there a shift
maybe in terms of the confidence in
terms of the motivation
the the mission-driven mentality how do
does this change at all
yes but i think it's also very personal
so for me it was like okay we found it
what's next i think it depends on the
other people may you know celebrate a
bit more and you know be in that moment
i'm like okay now how do we grow this
you know bigger
and faster and what do we do
need to do next but there's definitely
that moment where you see
okay we got it like this is the product
this is the category let's continue in
this uh
in this uh route but always kind of you
know finding what is the right exact
direction
incredible if you had to go back to roy
a
before
security things was just starting out
with everything that you know today
everything that you've experienced all
those countless hours of experiences
that are mounting
what would you tell him well what are
some things that he would say that are
non-trivial for a young entrepreneur to
know
don't do this
no i'm kidding
i don't believe you
i'd say it's a it's a great ride um work
you know find the the right people the
right team
enjoy the ride uh you know there's a lot
of uh you obviously i think in in a
startup when
you know when you build it as a ceo
you every that your um your response
your job changes all the time what
you're doing right that's different when
you're like
two people
five people 10 people 20 people it just
changes all the time so there's so much
you learn uh at the start which i think
is very hard to learn in it pretty much
in any other position
um especially as a kind of the ceo
um so it's hard to say uh because it
would be like a long session of hey hey
roy this these are the lessons learned
and there's been you know there's been a
quite a bit of lesson learned during the
this period
i love it roy if you had to choose a few
words to describe yourself or if i were
to ask anybody insecure things how would
you describe roy in three words what
would those words be
roy oh
that's a tough question i have no idea
i actually
enjoying the ride i'll take it but i was
gonna say that i that the answer he gave
me before that was my favorite answer
until now i have no idea i think that's
a that's just as good of an answer
yeah
probably some other people need to
answer that question
exactly roy thank you very very much i
really really appreciate your time your
energy your insights your background i
love the fact that you're chasing after
this new cat this new category you have
incredible investors that are that are
partnering with you with with great
validation and and i just think it's
such an awesome journey thank you so
much for sharing it with me and stay
safe and stay healthy
absolutely my pleasure michael thanks a
lot
thank you
you